first final in the tour and in a couple
of weeks ding will play in the
candidates tournament he is
definitely in great shape and of course
we're wondering actually now i'm seeing
prague has the white pieces that means
ding actually who scored the better in
the preliminaries has chose the chosen
star with the black that's very unusual
yeah very interesting maybe he just
wants to hold with black and um
in this manner he will end on a white
ding so he'll end
with a game that maybe he knows what
result he needs meanwhile heidi are we
going to see your favorite the nimzo
indian it looks like it yay great if
black's dark square bishop comes out now
we will see the nimzo indian defense
or ding could opt for the queen's gambit
declined by pushing the black pawn in
the center
forward two squares
what do you think we'll see i don't
think we're going to see the nimzo
indian i mean most of the top players
when given the chance to play it
they do it's a critical cutting edge
opening gives lots of fighting chests
and i was wrong we jinxed it we fixed it
it's the queen's gun but declined aha
and we did see uh that thing with the
white pieces though had a great score
with uh this opening yep very decent
scoreding and i think he's just an
expert on both sides of this type of
position with white with black dink has
been playing these positions since he
was very very young uh since he was even
younger than prague so we see
the exchange variation of the queen's
gambit declined a couple of pawns have
left the board now white stepping
forward with his own pawn black has a
variety of different setups different
moves in this position normally black's
bishop comes out
but light square bishop or the dark
square bishop can both develop at this
moment
okay first he challenges white's bishop
ship steps back
this is actually quite trendy ivanka i
know a lot of top players have been
playing this variation just in the last
few weeks alone
yeah yeah it is uh trendy and uh one
thing i just wanted to point out is that
the white queen by saying
well actually not the white queen by the
black the white knight not developing
the black hasn't been able to trade off
dark square bishops but anyway okay yeah
that means all pieces on the board and
it's likely to stay that way for a while
black's night now has developed and here
usually we see white's queen maybe take
a step forward
connecting the white rooks just
simple development there are other
options for prague you could step
forward with a couple of different pawns
maybe
um often we see the dark square bishops
leave the board in uh position like this
but black is a bit cramped black has
slightly less space than white so any
exchanges will help black and this pawn
push
this idea i'm not sure it was this exact
position but at least this idea of
pushing this pawn there was a very
famous case just two weeks ago and uh i
think it was fabiano caruana introduced
this move
one hour later jordan van faris played
the move as well and it had never been
seen before that one day and it was
played twice in the same day by two
different players on opposite sides of
the world so a really interesting pawn
push
yeah no i'm glad you said that david
because actually i've never seen it
before so now i i know this is cutting
edge theory i was like oh hang on a
second that's not normal but uh yeah
absolutely fantastic and dark squad
bishops off the board and this is the
big idea the pawn is just going to march
forward and take as much space as
possible yeah white's idea here with
this pawn push as you might mention is
firstly to gain space sometimes uh you
can kind of destabilize this black
structure by pushing even further
forward asking a question of this black
pawn either black will take you and ruin
the pawn structure or black will have to
bypass your pawn and you have this kind
of wedge in the position for an end game
this pawn is going to be very very
dangerous
so that's one interesting idea and also
you do have the option to maneuver your
knight into this dark square and this is
a very typical idea because this pawn
lies on a dart square black can never
really break out and challenge so you
have kind of created a semi outpost for
your knight
and yeah this was completely
new position until two weeks ago that's
how fast news travels in chess all the
top players going for this trendy
variation when when we learn how to play
chess or when we give good advice to new
people who play chess one of the advice
are that you shouldn't move the same
piece more than once in the opening but
here we see that uh prague has moved his
his pawn why why is that a good move um
this pawn forward
yeah i guess uh it's partly to gain
space i think prague has pretty much
completed development now um at least
with his minor pieces the non-minor
pieces are on decent squares very
centralized squares ready to kind of
play on both sides of the board
depending on what they need to do um i
am slightly surprised that he hasn't
moved his queen yet as uh as mentioned
for example um in the current position
he could move his queen connect his two
rooks and the rooks are flexible maybe
they'll want to play on this side of the
board supporting their pawns maybe
they'll want to play in the center later
another common idea would be to just
move the rook across one square later
kind of play for a pawn break in the
middle of the board
you're right there heidi i think he
should start developing you don't
necessarily want to get carried away
with any pawn pushes yet you want to
decide where your pieces go first
um and you also mentioned moving the
same piece several times black has moved
this night twice already
kind of re-routing it towards the king
side he's also moved this knight to the
edge of the board twice
so blacks may be lacking um in
development compared to white just
because he's messed around with his
knights black i think here ding would
love to get his bishop out for example
to develop it and uh he would love to
centralize his rook on the next go he
needs to get all of his pieces to better
squares
at the moment i think that's maybe why
the evaluation bar slightly favors white
just because white is uh slightly more
ready white also has more space thanks
to the advance of this pawn yeah
one of the things i found always very
uncomfortable with black
because i do have experience not exactly
in this particular position is that the
the light square bishop does develop but
it doesn't actually have a role you know
once black does all the happy moves then
uh he just has to sit and react to
whatever white comes up with
and uh it's gonna be an interesting um
battling ground and i'm just uh
i love the fact as david pointed out
earlier that this is like super new
theory
you know
like literally from
two weeks ago like you mentioned yeah
and now it's kind of like
but i mean this is just it's incredible
especially when you think about in the
past when players took it took weeks to
find new their new ideas and they were
scary magazines and uh actually we have
a very interesting move from white
deploying the the knight to the back row
in order to attack the black knight on
the edge of the board yeah maybe we can
show this because it looks really weird
retreating the knight back to the first
rank as ivanka said first of all there
is a threat that you have unleashed an
attack against the black knight which
now steps back actually to a better
square and i think prague's main idea is
sometimes you have to kind of take a
step back uh to go forward and uh yeah
sometimes it's just like in life you
have to admit a mistake in order to kind
of improve things in future and the
white knight is destined for this square
it does feel however like the white king
is a bit
well i don't say naked but it doesn't
have many protectors around it so at
some point we might see blacks pieces
kind of gravitate towards the white king
uh maybe simon i'm missing him in here
in the studio but maybe this idea of
pushing the black pawn forward because
the white king has no defenders and
that's normally a trigger that's a
signal that you should attack if your
opponent has no defensive pieces
uh meanwhile prague will try and play on
the opposite flank of the board white's
knights will start to jump in i'm not
sure what they're doing there but they
look nice and pretty all right but we're
basically out of the opening now just
about yeah both kings get it going to
safety
so all right
yeah and uh but we're going to talk
about openings for one second now
because we haven't launched the quiz of
the day right no we haven't lost the
quizzes yes i'm about to do it yeah and
of course you know this is the chassis
ball masters and it's all about openings
and we are asking for our quiz of the
day what is your opening
nightmare
we are asking you to recall all those
bad memories and uh it's a chessable
prize up for grabs and this time it's
the grand royal lopez by uh niels
grandelias he was actually playing early
on in the preliminaries
and uh well in order to have a chance to
win this awesome prize you have to tweet
your answer using the hashtag
chesschamps and yep just tell us your
deepest darkest opening nightmares
absolutely and um
later today we're going to deep dive
into the real lopez opening yesterday we
were talking about an opening that
looked really old the pictures of uh
the karo khan are you giving some
spoilers well because i checked some
pictures i wanted to find out who's
behind the real opus opening
and uh there weren't any pictures there
were only paintings
of the owner of that opening so it's an
old one
it's an ancient
it's so old yep but it you know has a
great uh history as you'll find out and
uh all this gold with the best openings
are the oldest ones oh okay and uh okay
ding just moves this rook across one
square again a bit mysterious he's maybe
just hinting that he'll push some black
pawns on this side of the board and
okay the move goes back to pragnanda
it's all about slow maneuvering and
planning and heidi you mentioned about
your chest strength but how would you
kind of describe your style what type of
positions do you like to play do you
like these kind of slow block positions
are you more direct yeah i prefer the
slow positions i like to maneuver and
whenever we play at my club i'm normally
the ones one of the ones that sit at the
end
so i finished really really really late
um
because i'm not that good at openings
i'm better at the end game
i've been working a lot more
on the end game than on the opening
so the further
along in the game you get the the higher
my chances of winning okay nice and i
think that's quite representative of
some of the viewers at home the opening
can be so hard to study it takes a lot
of time but working on end games you
found that's the way to
yeah yeah and but i realized i have to
uh because when i lose i often lose in
the opening so
i have to work a lot more in my openings
definitely so what is your i'm just
going to put the quiz of the day on you
what is your opening nightmare uh
it's the french defense meeting the
french defense it's the worst i it's so
bad that i uh when you play
um i don't know if i can see the the
moves now but when you i played e5 in
the second game just to sort of stop the
uh
uh stop the uh difference
oh that's radical yeah i know but
because i've lost so many games
but now i'm
i'm trying to learn so here you push
your pawn forward one square yeah yeah
just to
for example meet a pawn push with maybe
an exchange yeah in a trade so just to
show that point french defense it's a
scary opening but it's a terrible move
but then
then at least um my opponents don't know
what to do next so we're sort of on even
grounds i think i don't know what to do
and they don't know what to do yeah fair
enough and um we'll talk more about
opening nightmares in a minute but
i'm not sure whether this move is going
to give practice nightmares i would be
happy to see this one if i were prague
here as white because normally in this
type of pawn structure if you compare
the pawns in the middle of the board
white pawns point in this direction so
usually white is actually playing
towards this side of the board towards
the queen side black's pawns they
actually point towards this side so
black should be playing down towards the
white king uh by touching his pawns on
this side of the board
it goes against conventional wisdom it
does actually make this pawn a bit weak
it's a bit of a target now for example
if the white knight jumps out the way at
some point the white queen will attack
it the white rook can slide across to
attack it as well and it just feels like
ding maybe just a bit uncomfortable and
this pawn is going to cause him a lot of
trouble long term that being said he has
stopped these white knights from jumping
in these two white knights are
temporarily dominated by these two pawns
so i understand what he's doing i don't
like it too much myself but
maybe he just feels that he wants to
stop prague's plan he just wants to stop
craig's knights getting active and for
now that's enough for ding maybe he'll
just put his bishop on this square long
term to kind of protect its weakness
on the c6 square so still very cagey
maneuvering stuff
and how about yourself your anchor chest
nightmares
well if well i do have chest nightmares
actually and they only and almost always
involve the opening stage where i get to
the board and someone has played the
most ridiculous opening while my king is
being attacked and it's super sharp and
i don't know what i'm doing and then i'm
like this is not my game it doesn't make
these moves
and uh that is normally a quite
recurring nightmare i have to say um but
when it comes to
like opening nightmares is when my king
is unsafe
i i really don't like it if my king is
out there exposed
and you know i have no good place to put
it and well we've seen a trade of pawns
and since the circuits of the nights
have been dominated the night takes a
step back and uh set to find itself a
new home yeah maybe heading towards the
center of the board this is quite a key
square in the queen's camp it declined
the players are just using pattern
recognition to realize where they want
to put their pieces um also white does
have control over an open line now um so
it did take a long time white had to
push pawn forward once twice three times
um just to create an open line for his
rook but it can be quite effective and
look out for this rook at a convenient
moment moment maybe entering the black
position later on at the moment all
entry squares in the black half of the
board are covered you can't bring your
rook in but
it might be something that uh ding has
to be careful of mm-hmm and ding is
still not uh moved his um his um
yeah his bishop yeah true um and
actually ivanka mentioned that this is
the problem piece often in this opening
uh because no matter where you put it
even if you put it on a semi-active
square it actually gets
blocked in by its own pawns black's
pawns on light squares in the middle of
the board and therefore this is
technically a bad bishop if you compare
it to white's bishop white's bishop is
actually a really good piece because
it's kind of supported and complemented
by pawns on dark squares haunts control
dark squares bishop controls light
squares this is like the ideal formation
and that's why i slightly prefer white's
position that being said at the moment
black
doesn't have too many
threats to worry about
i would be starting to maybe develop the
black knight out i really want to kind
of start attacking towards the white
king somehow not sure exactly how you
break through but you need to improve as
heidi says this bishop and this knight
yeah and uh well ding is definitely
thinking about his plan in this first
game in the final i sent out to the good
night to simon his plan is to have fun
today what's happening simon
well i i'm in my natural habitat here at
chess pub uh there can't be a better
place in the world you can have a little
look there's not just chess going on
here there's obviously a bit of drinking
going on at this table as well uh but
there's plenty of games of chess going
on everywhere if the camera like springs
around but we do have
over here um a very special guest who
has his own podcast so um i'll just let
him introduce himself
if you just say your name please yeah hi
i'm david i'm host of 64 chess podcast
brilliant and we're talking about
openings today um what's your favorite
opening
my favorite opening is the carol khan
oh i feel sorry for you there um
sorry ivanka um but we're here and who
do you think is going to win the match
as well do you think it's going to be
prague or ding
i'm a big ding fan but you got to look
at progranando's games and i mean this
guy he's just he's doing something
really special right now i mean he has
he has finals or something in india like
he has school exams and he's coming and
he's just making world-class players
look like fools i
i don't know i can't bet against him
it's pretty amazing yeah you've said it
correctly then it's quite nice to have a
podcast to be interviewed for a change
but it's really heating up here there's
loads of people having a lot of fun uh
you can come down this is a place in
oslo everyone's welcome you can have a
drink play some chess the atmosphere is
fantastic and i'm watching you guys here
in the studio and i'm maybe having
a little a little a little drink um of
course that's only water because i'm a
professional
but yeah back to the studio
enjoy yourself simon and we will check
in with you uh later of course uh first
game in the final and chattable
is going on we did have a couple of
moves can we see dingley wren's plan in
this game we've definitely seen his plan
over the last couple of turns and
actually the position has changed
considerably since we last
since we last there and it's all to do
with pawns pushing forward and actually
just when we left it it was this
position black decided okay now is the
moment i thought maybe he would prepare
this with a night jump or bishop move
but no ding is far more direct he sees
the moment to push forward and
i'm slightly surprised here that prague
kind of left this tension
and these pawns looking at each other i
don't think you necessarily want to take
black's pawn because now black gets a
nice pawn center black's rook suddenly
this mysterious rook move from earlier
it suddenly looks like a genius stroke
because the rook is now on an open line
so prague decided okay
he just
brings his knight to a better square
defends his center and that has allowed
ding now to step forward again to be
honest i would have maybe brought my
bishop forward to attack the black rook
and just maintain the tension in this
way but now in the current position
after ding stepped forward attacking the
white bishop we do see white's bishop
move
offering a trade and now the black pawns
stepping forward and the reason i'm
slightly surprised is as heidi mentioned
this bishop is doing nothing it sat
there the whole game on its starting
square and white now is the one who's
just spent a couple of moves trying to
trade off a piece that's not really done
anything the whole game it feels like
white's lost a bit of time and uh
meanwhile these black pawns
long term watch out for them they're
going to start stepping down the board
they might be quite scary any end game
black is going to have a big advantage
because of these two pawns and they
could potentially become a past one
later in the game and white only has one
pawn to to protect yeah
these two later let's ignore the rest of
the pawns but these two are playing
against this one you're right so if all
of the pieces disappear black is
actually just going to win and uh yeah
prague needs to play a bit more
dynamically now maybe that involves
bringing the white knight into the
center we mentioned that this white
knight is on a great square
and uh juventus you taught me about this
one in this type of structure okay he
does play this there's actually a night
fork threatened as well the white knight
wants to jump into the c6 square
attacking the black queen attacking the
black rook
so um this is a big threat which ding
needs to defend against
i'm going to be honest with you here
david i hate pragnando's position and
it's not often that you'll hear me say i
hate but i mean it really
is to me a dream queen's gambit declined
and uh just look at those queen side of
those left pawns on the left i mean just
look at them they're so far up the board
and normally
they live somewhere else and they're
restrained and this is just feels like
it's so beautiful and also i i suspect
that the light squared bishops are going
to get traded off as you mentioned and
no problem whatsoever for ding yeah i
mean all you need to do is maybe guard
against this knight jump i'm not sure
exactly how for example you can move
your rook up the board and at some point
these pawns are just going to start
rolling kicking away the white knights
in the process
and you can even gain time kicking away
the white queen if you want with the
pawn push
yeah it does feel like things are
heading in ding's favor and look at the
evaluation bar i'm not sure whether
bishop takes bishop is even the best
move but
maybe there are options um the computer
liking black i think aesthetically it
looks great for black it's all because
of these pawns i'm not sure i should
have allowed them this far down the
board
and the openings that so this was the
queen's gambit decline inclined and um i
did take a look at the opening stats
here for prague with the white pieces
um it's a 60 percent oh let me find it
there we go
uh am i looking at the right i think he
has a 60 percent
score there we go
60 score but he's also lost two games
and won three games in this opening so
it seems like a risky choice yeah so i
mean it's regarded as quite a solid
opening for both sides but prague lots
of decisive results winning a few losing
a few in this opening
it doesn't feel like this one is
anywhere near a draw uh it definitely
feels like long term i mean short term
there's going to be imbalances pieces
all around
white has the open file but long term
black is the one with the trances so i
can't see this one fizzling out or
getting simplified or being safe for
either side anytime soon
it doesn't feel safe at all for whites
and
yeah i really don't like it i've said it
again i said it once i say it again you
know i just don't see what species are
doing and black has a very nice plan he
has the space
and i mean also i'd like to go back to
an idea that david mentioned many many
moons ago and that was actually maybe at
the right time once you've controlled
everything on the left you can actually
start advancing on the right you know
i've seen some beautiful plans from
alpha zero
where the pawn h pawn of course moves up
the board yeah later on um i i never
know why i it's hard so hard to explain
but just in this type of pawn structure
it's always black pushing towards the
white king maybe it's just because
white's king has no defenders around it
uh if you compare black's king has two
nice knights and that's the rhyme knight
on f8 there is no mate and black's king
is always going to be safe
once this knight sits here whereas the
white king no defenders so yeah that's
an interesting point for later watch out
for an attack black can maybe distract
white with these pawn pushes um okay
first he trades off the bishops
but uh okay wow now he goes for this
pawn push i said that this was a threat
the knight jumping in attacking the
black queen but ding has completely
ignored that he's attacking the white
knight now and if we see white threaten
the black queen maybe the black queen
just moves and after the white knight
captures this black rook
suddenly we see a situation where black
is temporarily down a rook for a night
but this white knight is almost trapped
it has nowhere to go to apart from the
side of the board and then suddenly look
at plaques pawns we talked about the
black pawns this one now attacking the
white rook and when the rook moves i
mean firstly this knight is hanging but
uh secondly these pawns are just rolling
down the board
it looks fantastic for ding i think
really well calculated now in the
current position i don't think parking
lander can get greedy and jump in with
his knight i think he would actually
lose if he did this he just needs to run
away with his other knight but that's a
step in the wrong direction if he jumps
back with his knight black is left with
these glorious pawns as heidi mentioned
is two versus one on this side of the
board short term and long term that's a
big big problem for white if you compare
white pawns these pawns are just going
nowhere
it's uh definitely advantaged right now
yeah those black pawns look scary and if
you were sitting on this board with the
white pieces heidi how would you feel
i would
not be very happy yeah it feels it feels
like the black girl pawns are coming so
close and where are you supposed to yeah
put your knight um
i would feel like i would just have to
defend the fen defend and uh
yeah i would not like it at all and i'm
quite surprised it it feels like it
changed so quickly i think uh pride
looked so confident he looked like um
he was going in the right direction and
now it just seems like he he couldn't
couldn't handle it yeah and actually
talking of the knights white's knight in
the center of the board on the e5 square
next to the white queen that has moved
six times to get there this other white
knight that's just retreated just
stepped back that's moved twice so he's
lost a lot of time with his knights and
especially the knight that's moved back
not a great piece anymore the knight in
the center of the board looks great but
it might just get traded off at some
point and then you've lost six or seven
moves and in the meantime black has used
those moves to start pushing his pawns
yeah it feels like prague is maybe just
playing move by move but ding has got a
bigger long-term strategy in mind and
now okay white's knight is safe so that
threat is in the air the other knight
jumping to attack the black queen i'm
sure ding will deal with that though
maybe one of the black rooks will move
maybe the black queen can move
lots of choice lots of pleasant choice
for ding
i know a lot of people who watch chess
play on an app or play against friends
and and one of those things that might
be quite difficult is when to push to
pause like you know now they're quite
far ahead but when do you actually try
to move them forward
definitely that's a very good question
um i guess the first thing i would be
looking for here for ding okay he
actually challenges uh this open line i
mentioned this was an open line he
challenges with his rook yeah the first
thing i would be looking for here is
okay can i push my pawns but the other
thing you have to kind of this is the
hardest thing in chess simultaneously
juggle what you want to do and what your
opponent wants to do and uh your
opponent here has this big threat of the
knight jumping in as we showed attacking
black's queen and rook so first i would
want to deal with that and
also
again it's it's such a hard decision
when to push these pawns i think at the
moment this square is covered
sufficiently it's covered twice by white
so you can't really push this one you
don't necessarily want to push this one
either because you block up your own
pawns
often actually pawns are much much more
i mean they have better potential when
they are side by side like this that
means you tease your opponent every move
your opponent has to worry about one
pawn pushing forward or the other one
pushing forward you don't really want to
for example just block things up and
lose the integrity of your pawns because
now for example what now is completely
blocked up you need to definitely um i
think when in doubt just keep your pawns
side by side that's the general rule um
just because
yeah they uh they are more flexible this
way it's not clear which one is pushing
but in the current position there was a
threat so ding moves his rook across
also long-term stuff like having
potential past porn
that actually becomes much much more
important in the end game
because the pawns will be harder to stop
if white doesn't have pieces to stop
them with
um so i think ding's strategy of trying
to trade off rooks um that helps long
term because then the pawns will become
even better
and
yeah i think that's a good point i mean
i've really struggled with pawns i still
struggle with pawn structures sometimes
um unfamiliar pawn structures especially
and meanwhile okay white knights are
looking okay i don't really know what
they're doing everything's defended but
uh they look okay for now
yeah and uh i think looking okay is okay
it's good when you need to be dynamic um
at least one night uh starts what has
eyes on the pawn in the middle of the
board which could be potentially quite
weak yeah black's defending it
sufficiently for now with one night but
as you might mention it's a target
and uh white is doing the right thing
you have when your opponent has strong
pawns you need to target the base of the
pawn chain um so this is the furthest
back pawn the protector so you want to
target the protector if this spawn falls
the rest of black's pawns might fall so
that is what prague is trying to do
meanwhile and we also always talk about
that f5 square the knights on f5 will
thrive both of the knights are very
close but they are not on f5 how big of
a difference is it in this position yeah
it's quite a big difference you're right
kaya the white queen she looks nice and
pretty on the f5 square but she's not
actually threatening or doing anything
um
again she's more worried about her own
appearance than
then actual kind of
influencing the game right now and ding
interesting decision he's been
consistent he's trying to force the
exchanges
okay this night jump
i'm not 100 sure about it it feels a bit
loose somehow
ivanka what do you think of uh
i mean knights coming off the board it
should favor black it should favor black
um i agree but i was more interested in
actually
pushing the queen back the white queen
you know it's
it's in the middle of the board and some
black side and i was kind of thinking
that that that queen should not be
anywhere over there but then again
uh
it's a solid move i feel i mean it's not
a disastrous move
but uh probably prague like you say will
be a little bit happy to see this type
of
moves
yeah i mean just instant wise it felt a
bit loose um i can't see a refutation
though i still
really don't like white's position
and maybe it's becoming a bit
time sensitive now if you allow all the
knights to disappear it's going to be
one-sided with black's pawns racing down
also pregnant he has had time trouble
issues and this is the type of position
that if you do drop down to one two
minutes on the clock it's so hard to
handle for white i think it's much
easier to play with black
um this type of position you can just
bully your opponent because you have
those pawns you can say okay i'm going
to trade off or i'm going to
try and trade things off you have to run
away from the exchanges
and uh difficult moments for the
teenager
taking under four minutes pregnant now
end game one and ding is as always just
looking super calm
super focused and probably super
confident after beating world champion
magnus carlsen yesterday
it's just in great shape the chinese
very good shape and heidi how are you
when you're low on the clock do you like
playing faster games for example
no i no that's terrible
i need a lot of time uh yeah i prefer
playing classical chess i'm a lot better
at classical chess than in
rapid than in in blitz okay so um i
normally when i play um a classical
chess if i have you know the clock if
it's under 20 minutes you start to see
the seconds countdown and then my heart
starts
so if you're in prague's shoes right now
you would be i would be i'll be quite
stressed yeah definitely yeah
that happens to me actually when i've
got less than a minute on the clock i
don't know it's like somehow i spend
most of my energy like looking at the
clock ticked down instead of actually
focusing on the moves but i've noticed
the top players actually
and especially david he's so calm he's
sat there and looking and then they let
their clocks go down to three seconds
and then they make a move and i'm like
okay well easy for some
others like you it's like the adrenaline
is pumping i'm making some crazy hand
gestures here then everywhere so yeah
nightmare and when i have like three
seconds left on the clock i don't press
the clock uh quietly it goes like really
fast
because i can't lose any time
yeah actually i was uh
well recently i played an opponent who
he would go down to one second every
single move and then not just that but
he after making the move he would stand
up and just circle the board he has like
he gains 30 seconds after every move but
he has 30 seconds and he was just
walking around me i was kind of like i
mean i know i'm quite calm but yeah he's
just
i don't know how he does it just ice
cold but did that mess with your head a
bit did he do that yeah
so much do you think it was his tactics
maybe he had really loud shoes as well
that's it yeah
yeah but
okay wow
yeah a night jump i didn't expect this
one i've got to say but not just that
but pregnant he was looking around he
looked like he was disturbed by
something maybe that's just the stress
of going under two minutes now on the
clock and this night jump for white
i mean he's offering a trade of one of
black's defensive pieces but
again it feels so strange again i'm not
sure what the exact idea is um if we
jump in
white's knight now going to the edge of
the board he's trying to attack this
black knight but for example if i just
trade it off
what has white really achieved here
everything that the white queen is
attacking or the white knight is
attacking they're actually defended very
well and uh here it might be time as
hard you mentioned to start thinking
about pushing one of these two pawns
forward
i'm not sure which one but white's
pieces have gone on the other side of
the board and that is normally the
signal once more if your opponent is
focusing on one side and you don't think
they have any threats you can play on
the opposite side of the board okay he
doesn't exchange off this knight though
ding jumps into the center
really brave these nights now make quite
a nice impression but uh okay is white's
knight strong on the side of the board
is it actually threatening anything that
is the question for prague
if he can utilize his two nights now to
form some kind of attack against the
black king he's doing great but if he
can't attack the black king then they
just look silly these nights
yeah what do you think of this
yes
i actually thought he would just capture
the night um but anyhow i here with this
night jump i kind of like it now that
i've seen it i think the whole idea is
to actually step the knight back to
the d6 square and uh
kick the white queen away yeah you can
kick the white queen back i'm not sure
where it goes but
yeah for example the white queen could
step back maybe attacking this pawn
and it's still unclear i mean if we go
to the current position uh white is
really here prague is begging for these
knights to come off the board he's kind
of chasing
the black knight around just offering
this trade i'm not sure i would capture
now maybe it's still fine white does
have the option of capturing away from
the center normally we say that this is
positionally undesirable taking pawns
away from the center but you do open up
a line for your rook potentially
normally you should capture towards the
center so you don't ruin your pawn
structure and the white king actually
has a nice safe escape square and uh
yeah i hear i'm expecting a night trade
finally but
um still feels like it should be good
for black the evaluation did not like
that
move i'm trying to figure out why i
can't see i can't see a tactic in the
current position
maybe you just exchange things off and
maybe just keep things simple and then
start
thinking about pushing one of these two
pawns
yeah i'm surprised it says that much i
know black is better and i think we we
have discussed how black's position is
easier to play because of these pawns
but
it's not winning yet
i just peeked at the computer and the
computer says
it's it's good for what it's good for
black regardless any night move is good
it's like night takes
but the best one is uh
my move that was a surprise
[Laughter]
jumping back to attack the queen when
the queen steps back she doesn't have
too many uh promising squares i guess
you can just defend your central pawn
with your queen and okay ding plays it
of course he finds the best move that's
why he's the world number two and i
think we're heading towards this uh
position the black queen will defend her
pawn and uh now black is actually with
the queen over on this side it's getting
ready to support some of these pawns
marching forward
interesting stuff
these two black knights are just perfect
defenders they actually cover a lot of
important squares
yeah they're the dream nights aren't
they the dream team
no nightmare there
oh
nice i like that one david
it's uh gosh it's really really tense in
this position and you know especially
because pragnanda doesn't have so much
time he's struggling with a minute
positionally you know
he's not down materials materially but
positionally he has to do a bit of
rework repair work and
yeah it feels like i could actually
swing any moment and wow
yay must be good news for prague
it can be traded off
[Laughter]
that's the problem the night's gone on
such a journey just to get there i mean
that knight has spent one two three four
five six moves to get there both white
knights have actually moved six times
and no trade yet one of the black
knights attacks the white queen now the
trade does happen so white's attacking
knight did disappear and
it's all about the knights jumping it's
so hard to explain or even figure out
why these knights have been dancing
around so much both the white knight and
the black knight now maybe they just
balance each other out they're both on
very decent active squares
i just don't really understand what
white's doing why it's queen and knight
alone they need backup they need support
to attack
but there is no backup the two rooks on
the open a-line they just balance each
other out black's queen does a great job
of defending all the pawns in her half
the queen is cut off as you mentioned
earlier that was a sign and i'm thinking
is it the time is it time now to maybe
get
going with those queens those thorns on
the left i keep saying queen side pawns
today
there are queensland pawns and maybe
about to become queens
yeah maybe even even uh even better
actually so if if he's uh be able to
queen uh ding which of them is the star
is it possible to say
already he is now
beth
beth the b porn is the star and uh the
reason why i would say beth the b porn
is the the queen because um basically
the knight can help control the queening
square yeah if you think about its
promotion squares ivanka said this one
could be supported by the black knight
later
but not just that this pawn is propelled
forward the queen is basically uh like
the engine behind the pawn pushing it
forward down the board and i think
there's going to be a pawn sacrifice
next move or on the next few turns from
ding it looks like this pawn is blocked
for now but i firstly i don't know what
white does for example you just move
your rook somewhere this black pawn is
just going to give itself up in order
for the other pawn to march down the
board and this pawn is going to cost
white a rook and okay prague he didn't
find anything better he just moved his
king
how does that improve the position i
don't know there's nine seconds left on
the clock he is under pressure it's time
now i think firstly you can uh i don't
know whether you trade a set of rooks
first but now it might be time to start
pushing this pawn forward a breakthrough
with your other pawn
let's keep an eye on the players because
pragmata must be so so stressed right
now
i think he's going to fall to defeat the
evaluation bar says what plus five
that means a new queen might appear on
the board it's incredible actually um
yeah i'm looking forward to the
bulldozer appearing and the the b pawn
making its way to its destiny all right
let's go forward then maybe trade a set
of rooks and the final touch would be
pushing this pawn forward or maybe even
jumping forward with the knight and next
move this pawn is coming there we go the
avalanche continues and the pawns yeah
this is what we call a porn storm
these two pawns winning the game we
called it earlier and it's happening um
so an answer to heidi's question earlier
when to push the pawns you just wait
wait wait until all your pieces are
ready and then you support the pawns
with your queen with your knight
and uh yeah he just needs to find the
right way i think prague
sorry ding here but prague is about to
fall to defeat it's partly about the
clock but things just been another level
it's not one big blunder from prague
it's just a series of small mistakes and
ding has smoothly
taken it
it just seems like the the white pieces
are too far away to defend and the black
pieces have more i can can support a lot
more
yeah you're right there
and uh i mean that white queen uh is
just completely cut off the white
queen's actually on the diagonal of the
promotion square of the black pawn but
black's knight cuts it off
i think the black knight can yeah there
we go take a pawn next move that pawn is
moving forward white's rook will
disappear
ruthless play by ding very very
impressive i feel like this is uh yeah
like you say model game
dream dream 35 moves as well so far yeah
with black yeah i think if anyone plays
the queen's camera decline then this
should be top of the list of games to
study
um i still i'm just surprised prague
allowed those pawns forward earlier in
the game but
okay what is this trick
the white rook wants to actually
sacrifice itself and to lure away the
black queen because the white queen
remember is attacking a pawn near the
black king if the black queen disappears
then white maybe has some counter-attack
against the black king i think he can
just protect
uh protect a few things here maybe we
jump in just to show uh prague he's so
tricky here in this position he's moved
his rook up the board if this pawn
pushes down now then i think his idea is
to actually shuffle across with his rook
this looks like a suicide mission for
the white rook giving itself up
attacking the black queen but if the
black queen gets deflected away now then
there's no longer protection of this
pawn this pawn now drops this is a check
and black's king can't actually escape
the checks if you run this way the white
queen drops back with the check if you
go back the rook drops with a check and
actually you just repeat the position
here the black king cannot hide safely
so actually a really nasty trick there
from ding i think the problem though is
in the current position this pawn
firstly you can maybe just move it
secondly you can just defend it with
your rook and once you defend your king
this pawn again is just going to win the
game
yeah i love that rook move it's just so
small but it's uh so good as well
because you you renew the threat
and uh super safe now king and rick this
is if they just castled no tricks either
from pragnanda and that's all you need
to do keep control of these wild
positions yeah at this point again white
just has to give up his rook for this
pawn at some point it's too good it's
going to become a new queen but i have
to kind of compliment prague for finding
a trick like this because you know you
can imagine if you didn't have too much
time on the clock this is something that
you could well fall into
i think i would definitely fall into
this trick into prague's trap if it was
a blitz game and there we go ding of
course he plays the safest move and
now this pawn is going to win the game
six seconds five seconds the clock is
ticking down and he has to make a move
no
okay he drops his knight back that's
clever as well but the knight is gonna
have to give itself up for the black
pawn it's better than giving up a rook i
guess but uh there we go the white
knight disappears
the white rook is attacked white's rook
can go somewhere but it's never going to
be able to attack anything black simply
has an extra knight
do you think pragnando will resign or
will he can kind of try to fight on okay
he's made a move he's a fighter we've
seen that
i've seen him save miraculous positions
in the tour this season
yeah the problem is for white there's
nothing to bite on there's nothing to
attack white's queen and rook they're
just looking at pawns that are really
well defended black's queen is free to
run around and there we go attacks the
white rook kicks the white rook out of
the black half
i think we might see prague resign in a
few moves yeah you can kind of see on
his in his eyes that he he knows he's
lost this yeah he looks ready to resign
pregnant but he's not going to resign
the match we did hear in his interview
yesterday he lost
a game four to a niche to take it to tie
breaks and uh no problem he was ready to
fight again and he did win in the blitz
tie breaks he doesn't seem to be too
affected by losses i think it helps him
as well though it's a two-day match
and ding half of ding's attention will
be on the candidates i think when you're
young it's nice to kind of draw things
out make your slightly older opponents
tired
prague's definitely not going to be out
of this even if he loses today's match
overall
okay pushing a pawn now in front of the
white king
the black knight though just
strong strong peace it's a free piece
and it's a strong piece
i feel quite sorry for prague who had to
have his exam today yeah i'm like why
couldn't his teachers just let him off
for one day yes as well right you know
the biggest chess talent in india maybe
just you know can take the exams next
week yeah pretty good excuse you know
playing against the world number two
chess player in one of the biggest
events of his life
so far at least
yeah do you find it difficult heidi to
bounce back from defeats
um
yeah yeah because i started questioning
everything about myself when i lose
chest not just my chest and playing
skills like my whole life and yeah
so it's very hard i take losses very
very hard
it seems to be something about chess
with you know losses even having you
question your life choices
and we do have a result pregnant he does
lose the first game and the final in